[Musique]
vous avez aujourd'hui sans doute une
journée très chargée mais en tant que
journaliste je dois vous demander
comment vous évaluez les derniers
événements au karabagh et autres guides
c'est une tragédie un super jeu voilà
nous sommes très inquiets notamment je
te prête parce que l'azerbaïdjan à rémy
ni l'arménie du nagorny-karabakh
ce sont des territoires où vivent des
personnes qui ne nous sont pas étrangers
il suffit de dire qu environ 2 million
d'azéris et plus de 2 millions
d'arméniens vif sur le grand territoire
de la russie
romain un grand nombre de citoyens
russes entretiennent d'étroites
relations amicales et même familiale
avec ces deux républiques à clichy ou
bien sûr bien sûr c'est une immense
tragédie
des gens meurent les deux côtés
subissent de lourdes pertes
ça m'oblige à chevry nous espérons que
ce conflit prendra fin dans un avenir
très proche mais il n'est pas
entièrement résolu les potions et
apparemment il y encore un grand chemin
à parcourir
et quoi qu'il en soit ce que nous
appelons et je tiens à le noter encore
une fois nous appelons à l'instauration
d'un cessez le feu
est ce le plus rapidement possible voilà
en général ce que je voudrais bien comme
vous le savez l'arménie est membre de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective
l'hôtesse et nous avons certaines
obligations envers l'arménie en vertu de
ce traité
mais les hostilités à notre grand regret
se poursuivent toujours et cela ne se
passe pas en territoire arménien quant
au respect par la russie de ses
obligations en vertu de ce traité
nous les avons toujours remplissent
borgniet l'expo nous les remplissons une
continuerons de les remplir qu'à croiser
un été comme vous le savez jour je suis
en contact permanent avec le premier
ministre arménien et les dirigeants
arméniens pour sauver non aucun doute
quant au respect par la russie de ses
obligations dans le cadre du traité au
kirghizstan une situation politique
interne très compliqué c'est une fois de
plus développé dans l'histoire récente
du pays
qu'en pensez vous que puis je dire à ce
sujet samedi dès les élections
parlementaires se sont tenus récemment
par ailleurs il a été reconnu non
seulement par les observateurs
internationaux mais aussi par les
représentants de l'organisation pour la
sécurité et la coopération en europe
l'osce et qu'elle s'était déroulée de
manière démocratique et conforme aux
normes ce qui s'est passé ensuite bien
sûr nous inquiète
nous espérons que tout se déroulera de
manière pacifique
nous espérons qu'un processus politique
démocratique normale sera rétablie et je
le répète encore une fois cela doit
avoir lieu le plus rapidement possible
nous sommes en contact avec tous les
participants avec toutes les parties à
ce conflit et je veux espérer qu'après
la normalisation de la situation
politique interne ne continuerons à
mettre en oeuvre tous nos projets avec
le kirghizstan est mieux douche
le kirghizstan est membre de l'union
économique eurasiatique et nous avons
beaucoup de travail à faire
conjointement nous prêtons au
kirghizstan une aide significative quant
à l'allocution des fonds de crédit off
et quant au processus d'entrée dans
l'espace de l'union économique
eurasiatique sérieuse d'un nouveau
procès dans ce cadre il existe de
nombreuses questions liées aux douanes
ou contre aux phytosanitaires etc
nous allons des ressources importantes
pour que le kirghizstan soit un membre à
part entière jouissant de tous les
droits de cette organisation parachute
mais je le répète encore une fois nous
espérons que tous les processus
politiques internes auxquelles nous
assistons aujourd'hui rendront fin et se
termineront rapidement sans aucune perte
brusque bien ce que tu écris pop a tiré
j'ai quelques questions sur les
événements de ces dernières semaines il
ya dix jours vous avez lancé un appel
aux états unis pour les
exhorter à reprendre la coopération dans
le domaine de la sécurité de
l'information
avez vous reçu une quelconque réponse
idiote non malheureusement une de même
que pour toutes un nombre de nos autres
initiatives à ce sujet qui est très
important à mon avis nous n'avons pas
reçu de réponse bien que des accusations
soient toujours proférées quant à notre
activité trop intense prétendument trop
intense dans le domaine de l'information
ainsi que des accusations liées à notre
ingérence dans les élections la barre et
ainsi de suite sans aucun fondement le
monde entier observe maintenant la
dernière étape de la course
présidentielle américaine est bien sûr
beaucoup de chose se passe là bas au
niveau certaines choses auraient été
inimaginables dans le passé mais ces
dernières années il ya quelque chose qui
ne change pas il mentionne constamment
votre nom de plus sur des débats récents
qui ont suscité un tel émoi même le
candidat byden a dit du candidat trump
qu'il était le caniche de poutine
considérant qu'ils parlent de vous tout
le temps je voudrais poser une question
à laquelle vous ne voudriez probablement
pas répondre mais néanmoins je la
poserai quand même dans cette course
présidentielles vous sentez vous plus
proche des positions de trump ou de
biden
c'est aux électeurs de chaque pays
d'évaluer la position des candidats à la
présidence même s'il s'agit de la grande
puissance que sont disons le ouvertement
les états unis en l'occurrence c'est aux
américains de le faire nous ne sommes
que des observateurs
nous n'intervenons pas star une ignoble
dette et les moniales mieux quant à la
brutalité mutuelles ou les insulte
directe que vous avez évoqué que dire de
son premier nous cela reflète leur
niveau de culture politique ou son
absence de politique ce qu'écoutent tour
mais je le répète tout jeune nous ne
nous immisçons pas dans cette affaire
benhima a pas tout cela est motivée par
des processus politiques internes qui
est des questions de politique
intérieure et des problèmes inhérents
aux états unis catégorie d'ailleurs
quand quelqu un essai du pilier ou
insulter le président en exercice ou
graves ou soudan l'occurrence dans le
contexte que vous avez évoqué tac lnh
est double rifi d'une certaine manière
en estimant que notre influence et
autre puissance sont énormes et moins
dans une certaine mesure cela comme on
dit le fait notre jeu et qu'on sonne à
rudy vodonon achemine mais je le répète
cela ne nous regarde pas
il y en a chez dire qu ils le gèrent
eux-mêmes de la manière qu'il trouve
approprié dans la situation actuelle
c'est la chasse abouti non gaap est
quant aux préférences que peut-on dire
on n'en aime ce taux nous savons que le
président en exercice donald trump ni
arnaque s'est exprimé à maintes reprises
en faveur du développement des relations
américano russes
certes nous apprécions beaucoup cela dès
le début quand il en parlait dans le
premier acte de la course à la maison
blanche
nous y avons fait attention au minimum
non inodore mais il faut examiner les
évènements de ces dernières années d'une
manière objective d'agi effectivement il
ya eu beaucoup de progrès dans les
relations bilatérales
il faut le dire je ne vais pas citer
l'ensemble des mesures positives prises
dans le cadre du développement des
relations russo américaines
jusqu'à mes 15 mai elle d'exister liste
pour les mines et les eaux malgré tout
les intentions exprimées auparavant par
le président trump globale et orange
dont n'ont pas été pleinement mises en
oeuvre et j'estime que cela est lié dans
une large mesure au consensus bi
partisan sur la nécessité de faire
barrage à la russie se dit allez et
entraver le développement de notre pays
un pays chaud
cette position s'applique dans tous les
secteurs je dois être content il s'agit
de la dissuasion tout azimut et c'est la
première chose est bien évidemment à
notre sens cela constitue une entrave
pour l'administration en exercice
administrateurs en outre pris plaisir
c'est la présidence de trump est marquée
par le plus grand nombre de restrictions
et de limitation stricte et avenue
chénier sur le tce 46 décisions ont été
prises concernant l'imposition de
nouvelles sanctions ou l'extension des
sanctions existantes 10 touchés
d'administration trump
retirer du traité de force nucléaire à
portée intermédiaire cheerios c'est une
décision très grave cette naïveté
shifter lovegood administra prêt l'année
2002 quand sous l'administration bush
les etats unis se sont retirés du traité
sur les missiles balistiques
la bm non mais c'est la deuxième
décision d'une telle importance bien à
mon avis c'est très dangereux pour la
stabilité et la sécurité internationales
du monde entier et maintenant
l'administration trump a annoncé le
début du retrait du traité ciel ouvert
tanimou je ne peux pas ne pas être très
préoccupé le nombre de projets communs
modeste mais quand même n'ont pas été
mis en oeuvre
il s'agit de la mise en place d'un
conseil d'affaires d'un conseil
d'experts et pourtant je le répète une
fois de plus la présidence de trump a
été marquée par une hausse des échanges
commerciaux
il s'agit d'une croissance considérable
malgré toutes les restrictions et même
la pandémie il y a eu probablement des
ajustements face à la pandémie
mais la tendance générale est à
l'augmentation des échanges et c'est
bien parce que cela implique des emplois
de l'activité commerciale etc etc je
nous avons coopéré d'une manière assez
efficace sur la stabilisation du marché
mondial de l'énergie
bien évidemment les états unis ont
intérêt à maintenir une certaine
stabilité
virginia assurer le fonctionnement de
leurs compagnies pétrolières unis nous
sommes effectivement parvenus ensemble à
un bon résultat vous voyez il y à des
progrès et il y a des problèmes quant au
candidat du parti démocrate que dire
tout ça nous entendons un discours anti
russe assez ferme sa g légumes
cosmopolite malheureusement nous y
sommes déjà habitués lee et steve hill
et il y a des choses à remarquer tout
juste octobre et kim tout d'abord
traditionnellement le parti démocrate
partage plutôt les valeurs dites
libérales libéré
idées sont plus proches de celles des
sociaux-démocrates bâtir si on établit
un parallèle avec l'europe à se tordre
démocratique et c'est dans le milieu des
sociaux-démocrates qu'est né à l'époque
le parti communiste bouffe cependant
presque 20 ans 18 ans que j'ai été
membre du parti communiste de l'urss
et d'avouer à vrai dire j'étais un
simple membre du parti mais d'une
manière générale on peut dire que
j'étais assez engagé j'apprécie toujours
de nombreuses valeurs de gauche c'est de
cirque pour l'égalité la fraternité quoi
qu'y at il de mal
christ en effet cela ressemble au
christianisme il est difficile de les
mettre en pratique mais elle reste quand
même très attrayante
ainsi sur le plan idéologique et il y à
une sorte de base pour établir des
contacts avec le représentant du parti
démocrate cas que des villes comme on le
sait
aux etats unis les afro américains aux
taux y constitue une des bases
électorales du parti démocrate
j'aime partir ça chouette a toujours une
base stable gnagna que c'est bien connu
je ne fais aucune découverte ça use ça
use
bastian mais l'urss a toujours soutenu
la lutte des afro américains pour leurs
droits légitimes à beijing au soir parce
qu'aucun jeu comme interne que sort dans
les années 1930
l'internationale communiste écrivait que
les représentants de la classe ouvrière
noire et les ouvriers blancs avaient le
même ennemi à jean bracq et un ip
réalise l'impérialisme et le capitalisme
nains pessalle attend justement
soulignons que ce groupe pouvait être le
plus efficace dans la lutte
révolutionnaire dans l'avenir sur des
bribes la taxe d'eau et ici il y à
quelque chose qui est dans une large
mesure à défaut de nous réunir et de
nous rapprocher du moins il digne en
constituent nos valeurs communes et je
n'hésite pas à le dire mais ça n'est pas
publié si vous vous souvenez vous êtes
jeune mais les gens de ma génération
s'en souviennent
il ya eu un moment où partout on y est
il y avait de grands portraits d'angela
davis membre du parti communiste
américain et militante pour les droits
des afro américains sauf m c'est pour ça
qu'on estime qu on peut en parler et que
cela constitue une certaine base pour
notre compréhension mutuelle mais il ya
d'autres choses
par exemple le candidat joe biden a dit
en public qu'il était prêt à prolonger
le traité new starck ou à conclure un
nouveau traité de réduction des armes
stratégiques offensives et cela
constituerait un élément très important
de notre potentiel coopération dans
l'avenir est au monde c'est pour ça que
je voudrais répéter l'idée que j'ai déjà
évoqué à maintes reprises sur le boum
nous allons coopérer avec le président
américain quel qu'il soit ce thème avec
celui qui gagnera la confiance du peuple
américain
immelt
[Musique]